I want to start by saying congrats on
the movie you did a great job you did a
great job
Thanks and I'm done I'm out okay there's
a there's so much I want to talk about
but I think the one thing that would be
easiest for the two of you together is
filming the battle the big battle scene
in the third act it was look like the
armor was real heavy noisy it looked
like it might have been a really really
tough shoot was it tough I think David
could speak to it better than I could
but it was it was and uh and maybe I
could Kyle's going through it's maybe I
could be better - yeah but it was uh it
was hot it was muddy and I think it was
important to David that we weren't going
for like a Jedi fight sequence it was
not a swords and horses movie in the
sense that there were some sequence
rattled off that it was reminiscent of a
videogame a Mortal Kombat or something
but rather that you felt the
claustrophobia of the armor the
claustrophobia of the period the idea or
the fact rather that more people died
nagging core from drowning than from
blunt-force trauma from stab wounds and
just from general exhaustion so I think
that was the goal of it as opposed to
you know a lot of these kinds of movies
you see uh you see the Jedi type
sequence but it's you know choreographed
all in advance yeah I had it felt it
felt chaotic and hysterical and it was
really hard and in one of the things I
really loved about that battle sequences
the stuff that was frightening us on the
day you know which was like Timmy's in
the middle of that stuff and we were
having to worry about not killing him
you know because it was it was scary
yeah III sofiane it was good and he
lived we still had the shoot so I was
like I didn't really care about you yeah
if it gets your mommy yeah well one of
the things don't want to talk about is
you know before every big battle the
leader usually gives a speech and I'm
curious what it was like for you getting
ready you're looking at all these troops
and you really are on horseback or I
mean not on horseback but you have to
give that speech know when it starts on
horseback it does I was I was right so
talk a little bit about that and also as
like a co-writing what does it like to
write those words to try to inspire
there's a big group of men to possibly
give their lives I think one of the
great gifts of this role is if you're
playing someone who's finding their
voice
you don't in fact I think from an acting
perspective you don't want to modulate
that you want to you don't want to chart
that I had the gift of the organic
experience of trying to find that voice
of that character too and so that it
finds its peak or its its truest moment
of searching in that speech I think and
to that point you know there's an I give
it away but there's a scene with
Falstaff we can say the night before or
it's alluded to that if there isn't an
organic sense to the speech at least
give them a I at least give the troops a
magnificent lie because you know they
deserve it and as the leader that's we
grow them and so I felt like I felt like
the anti Braveheart in that way in that
and anyway I'm not you know I'm not
carrying weight like Mel Gibson or
anything so it felt like you know a room
the the room to have a speech that is as
much about nationalism and as much about
riling up an army with a genuine intent
and as much as it is as in as much as it
was about smoke and mirrors and smoke
and mirrors Menasha yeah practical sense
is just testament to like Timmy's skill
and and his talent it's like that's big
speech and it's powerfully to live it
and everything and it's like you know we
did it like 15 20 times they're any less
experienced actor would have lost their
voice after two guys but you know it's
like it's you were in there every time
doing it big and so yeah yeah yeah